I am viola I'm data scientists that we
function in to start up and I'm going to
be talking today about why and how I
dare use deep learning in the context of
statistical inference I'm going to play
a bit at first with a great data set
from OkCupid
it's about 60,000 OkCupid users who
answered some demographic questions so
often a times as a data scientist you
would ask yourself a very basic question
is the relay is there a lake a relation
between one variable and another here
I'm asking the silly question but I'm
asking it is the relation between
persons age and a person's height and
it's a very simple question you can plot
you know the the data with a simple
scatterplot to me this plot is intuitive
I say that for say adult women I think
there is no relation and even the
statistical test to answer the question
is it significant or not are you right
or not is pretty simple it's looks like
a linear relationship you would probably
compute a Pearson's R coefficient okay
for linear correlation here it's in
absolute zero of course it's not
significant and the answer is intuitive
a different question might be a relation
between two categorical variables is the
relation between ethnicity being white
or Asian and a reported drug abuse here
it's categorical like never sometimes
some of you might go for percentage
tables saying for each ethnicity what is
the percentage of people who answer
never sometimes often and some would use
a mosaic plot okay on the x-axis is the
ethnicity on the y-axis is
drug abuse reported okay and here
without knowing how many people answer
the survey it's a bit more difficult to
know whether what I what I'm saying is
significant or not I'm telling you that
it's 60 thousand respondents so it's
pretty significant if you want to do
this statistical test you would probably
use a chi-square test or a reporter the
results with the chromers V correlation
from Earth V is like it's a correlation
coefficient between zero and one where
zero is no relation and one is perfect
dependency and it's very significant
here you can see that for example Asian
respondents are statistically tend to
statistically use drugs less okay and
sometimes the relation will be between a
categorical variable and continuous
variable like here I'm asking whether
there is a relation between sexual
orientation and height and here
specifically sexual orientation say it's
between straight and gay respondents
obviously when it comes to height you
need to plot men and differen women on
separate plots if we look at the at the
Left plot its swirl plot okay another
plot I don't think to me there is a
relation in either of the plots but it
turns out when you look at the numbers
that straight men on average report that
they are one person one seven senator
centimeter higher than gay men and
surprisingly unless if you do a t-test
okay we had a person our correlation we
had a chi-square test here it's a t-test
then it's very significance with these
this many respondents I don't know if it
reflects any truth also could reflect
the fact that straight men tend to
exaggerate when it comes to reporting
their height I don't know
okay but so far we had pretty simple
questions and and plots what if I ask if
there is a relation between height and
income okay so again two continuous
variables and we do a scatter plot but
here the scatter plot is less obvious
okay it's less obvious but what to
answer to this question on the left you
see men on the right you see women and
the income is at log scale so when it
comes to men to me it doesn't seem like
there is a relation but when it comes to
women's to women maybe there is a
relation and if I ask what is the
relation you know to model the relation
that's a whole different question and
I'm not sure how to do this in this in
this specific scenario so usually life
is more complicated life that real data
looks more like this not like what I've
shown you before and many many questions
arise especially when you're a beginner
practitioner like should he or sure
should I use the correlation coefficient
is that okay so I'm hoping before that
you would ask is the pattern even linear
with women definitely wasn't oh I heard
there was a Spearman correlation
coefficients in statistics 101 and it's
a parametric so I can probably use that
whenever right can I use that here can I
can I use that that this number and put
it in my article should I just use the
log transformation for income is that
okay many questions arise if if you're
good at what you're doing I hope that at
least if you use a linear model you will
then do a perform some kind of
Diagnostics and like look at the
residual plot and say okay if his
marriage residual Pollock a decision I
know
Oh sometimes people would approach me
and because I am in my medication I'm a
statistician and say it doesn't seem to
me like there is a relation can I just
write
that you know everyone can can look at
it and reach the same conclusion okay
so visual inference is an approach which
is fairly new it's about 10 years old
and it aims to eliminate all this you
know all these questions but what does
she do the key to understanding visual
inference is that we treat the plot as a
statistics the same way that a mean of a
vector is a statistic of of the vector
of the data the plot is also statistics
and as a statistic U is a function of
the data from from whatever space your
data lives in into a 2d canvas and as a
statistics you can gather more of it you
can permute your data right you can
jumbled jumbled up one of the columns of
your data get a different slightly
different data and get another plot and
do it again and get another plot and do
it again and get another plot okay and
you can judge your plot your original
plot versus a distribution of these per
muted plots okay and you killed it you
can do it to ever plot a small plot a
mosaic plot a scatter plot okay under
the null hypothesis if there is no
signal in your plot in your data they
should all look the same you shouldn't
be able to discriminate your original
plot from the set of plots okay or if I
say ask 10 people ask you guys I
shouldn't be able to get one specific
obvious answer it is assumption free it
is parameter free and the question is
how to present this set of plot right
now the most common way to do this is
with what we call a line up protocol so
here I'm asking whether there's a
relation between a car's engine
displacement and its horsepower one of
these plots is the original plot the
other 19 are permuted plot where
jumbled up deidara and replated it and
I'm asking you which blood do you think
is doesn't belong here which plot is the
most unique which plot has the most
clear signal I'm hearing all kinds of
answers I'm here five and I'm hearing
1116 ok so let's wait for the answer
here I'm asking whether there's a
relation between a person's gender and
the answer to the question is it true to
bring a baby on plane it's a real survey
ok so here we have female and male and
the answer is no somewhat and yes which
plot is the most extreme plot do you
think 18 ok here I only heard 18 maybe
someone what sorry I didn't hear and
here we ask is the relation between an
actor's gender and the number of roles
since his or her character ended we have
here 120 129 actors in us shows which
were nominated for a Primetime Emmy
youth drama shows and the number of
roles and actor had after his or her
character ended is between 4 or 5 and 15
years after that and again I'm asking
which plot is the most extreme 19 anyone
else 0 I that what pops to my mind is
that I'm hearing on less answers because
it's hard to to get the answer and here
i if I'm not mistaking the the original
plot was 5
so I would say that according to this
test there is no difference between
women and men and in fact if you do if
you perform the statistical test any
statistical test I form several because
you can form several statistical tests
here
that's dense the answer you're gonna get
there's no difference okay and this is a
good example where the statistical test
isn't that obvious but we've seen that
you can do it on any type of plot okay
so this line up protocol some would say
it monetizes statistical inference
because it has been shown that kids can
do it naturally everyone can do it you
don't have to prove to me that a t-test
is a uniformly most powerful test to do
this you don't seem to get better I
added over time you just most people are
just good at it but it takes you less
time there are all kinds of studies that
have been done on it and most research
is on scatter plots and there's a lot of
usage in Amazon Terk because usually you
would want a p-value and you would ask
say n people what they think and you
under the null hypothesis
it's a bonala it's a binomial
distribution if they if people choose
the specific original plot okay so wait
well where is that deep learning come
into into display so judging a plot to
me immediately pops up as classifying an
image right it's a classification desk
and some data scientists some stirs many
statisticians have a slight aversion to
deep learning and you know shoving it
wherever you want but I claim it's very
good for computer vision and here the
idea is to take a neural network and
give it thousands of such plots you know
for scatterplot
for example you could sample from a
bivariate normal distributions thousands
tens of thousands on hundreds of
thousands plots you know and for each
plot give it let it predict whether it's
significant or not whether what is the
correlation if you're if you're giving
it many many many mosaic plots like I
have asked you to predict the chromers
v-- or a swarm plus a stick to predict
the T statistic or again whether it's
just statistically significant or not
trained to predict a correlation and
it's very important this difference not
calculate the correlation predict it and
if it's good show you the lineup and if
it chooses the original plot then yes
it's significance okay okay so I've used
a really basic architecture of a
convolutional Network basically you see
this plot it becomes my image my my data
matrix and it goes through the network
and at the end I'm expecting an answer
in this case I'm expecting a linear
correlation like 0.73 okay nothing
really fancy and it turns out that it
it's kind of good here you can see the
results on a test set with where I've
I've sampled
tens of thousands of from a sample size
50 from say above variate normal
distribution and we see that the network
predicts the our correlation and pretty
good here is when I sampled tens of
thousands of by categorical
distributions where you can see that the
network predicts the chromers be pretty
well and it is able to pick the original
plot so I owe you the answer here
everyone says 18 and indeed 18 here it
was 11
and up until now you might be wondering
so what I mean
convolution of networks can drive a car
so obviously they can you know
approximate the formula for linear
correlation it's not a very difficult
formula to to approximate but things do
get interesting and interestingly they
get interesting when I start looking at
the computers errors where it was wrong
and I wonder whether it was really wrong
this is the computers largest error okay
the actual correlation here if you
compute it is point four six but the
computer thought that correlation was
point one okay to me I tend to agree
more with the computer because this is a
I think a classic case of an an outlier
and next edition might use something
called cooks distance or whatever
whichever strategy you want to verify
that these two observations are actual
outliers and indeed when you just take
one of them the correlation drops to
point zero eight so some would say that
the computer was wrong but some would
say it would act it was actually pretty
robust to outliers and when you look at
this as a general pattern which is what
the computer learned you wanna see the
general pattern you don't want to see
the two specific observations which make
your your correlation higher than it
should be okay but things do get wrong
and obviously the learning has its
limitations I can give you a few
examples here I asked the computer
whether there was a relation between a
car's engine displacement and this time
its fuel economy so on the x-axis is
displacement and the y-axis is miles per
gallon what do you think is the most
extreme plots does nine right it's easy
for us but the computer after all there
you know chose zero why is that because
the computer never saw a nonlinear
relation okay while we see all kinds of
patterns and we don't have to be trained
on tens of thousands of plots okay
here the actual correlation is point 64
but the network predicted point two and
this is why the network point predicted
point two point two because it was
always shown and its sample size of 50
it was never shown a sample size of 10
it doesn't know what to do with it and
even though this is a very impressive
result if you're a social scientist the
computer the computer was unimpressed
also you can input to a deep learning
network whatever you want okay we know
this is a trick question and Cartman
isn't really a plot but the network
predicted that it has correlation of
minus forty three point nine nine which
is kept at minus one so the network
thinks that Cartman is negatively
perfectly uncorrelated okay but it just
goes to show how better we are as you
know as human judges perceivers as these
things then the in computer but I'm not
sure it's always going to be like that
okay and whenever you you know you shove
in deep learning to to the play you have
to ask yourself is it does it have any
value so if I count a number of plots I
have ever looked at and I'm a
statistician say from really optimistic
like three a day five days a week 52
weeks a year nine years since I
graduated I get to have seven thousand
but my laptop can look at twenty
thousand scatter plots in one minute my
laptop can look at every scatter plot
which was ever printed in every
statistical textbook ever scatterplot
that Ronald Fisher ever looked at and
every scatterplot that Carl Pearson ever
looked at in the course of one minute is
my laptop a better decision than me I
would say no I think I just proved that
but could it be a better system with me
maybe I'm I didn't even write that here
because I didn't want to be that guy
that would automate statistics but you
know this is where it is going to
especially when it comes to Diagnostics
and looking at residual plots which is a
tedious work and as any student of
statistic on one would tell you don't
really know don't really know what to do
with this residual pass and are they
okay or not okay okay so I'm not going
to be that guy who works on this project
but I am I'm I promise you that
somewhere someone is doing that and I'm
not sure that it's not an okay thing to
do okay there are many automated
platforms these days
which don't do any kind any form of
Diagnostics maybe they should be no
improved by doing that and not just
doing automatic T tests and this is one
way they could do that so thank you
these are my remove references and if
you have any questions I will answer
them now now well I don't think you can
do anything that's abuse with this
information tomorrow morning
but I think it shows you how statistics
can be automated in a way that would
save a lot of citizens a lot of time in
the future and in a good way you know
not just you know streaming data into an
automatic automatic t-test and just
getting the result but actually doing
the agnostic real diagnosis unreal there
Gnostics plot that's one example
no the short answer is no I only did it
for for tens of thousands of scatter
plots by sampling a bivariate normal
distribution and for tens of thousands
of sake plots by sampling tens of
thousands of by categorical distribution
and then later I made all these
adversary'
examples that you've just seen but
opacity is a great way to affect the
model and yeah that's a great addition
to this okay thank you
you